Now, we'll talk about a much
more efficient approach called
the simplex algorithm.
This actually will not be
polynomial time in the worst case.
But as a practical matter,
this algorithm is efficient
enough to be widely used.
The simplex algorithm allows us to
move from one basic feasible solution
to a better one.
And by moving to better and
better basic feasible solutions,
we eventually reach the optimum.
For convenience,
let's suppose that our current basis
consists of the first m columns of A.
We'll call this sub-matrix B and
the remaining sub-matrix D.
It will also be convenient to partition
X and C in an analogous fashion.
Over all then, we can write our
standard form linear program like so.
CB transposed times XB +
CD transposed times XD
subject to the constraints that B times
XB + D times XD must be equal to B.
And, of course, both XB and
XD must be non-negative.
For the simplex algorithm we want to
consider the effects of swapping out
one of the current basis columns for
another one.
To do this we first want to
identify a good candidate for
moving into the basis.
One that will improve
the objective function.
As the program stands however,
it's not immediately clear which
if any are good candidates.
Sure for some XI in XD here,
the corresponding coefficient
might be positive.
But raising the value
of that variable might
force others to change
because of the constraints.
Making the whole picture rather opaque.
Therefore, it would be convenient to
parametrize our ability to move around
in the flat defined
by these constraints,
solely in terms of the variables in XD,
the variables that we're thinking
about moving into the basis.
By the way, I'll use the idea
of moving variables and
moving columns into the basis
interchangeably throughout.
To this end, we solve the equality
constraint for XB, so
that we can substitute for
it where desired.
First, we substitute it into
the objective function, and
through a little manipulation,
we get this expression.
This constant term here doesn't matter
since we're only considering the effects
of changing XD.
This quantity that gets
multiplied with XD however,
is important enough that
it deserves its own name.
We'll call it rD.
In our reframing of
the problem therefore,
we want to maximize rD
transpose times XD.
How about the other constraints?
Well, the first one goes
away with the substitution.
This requirement however,
that XB be non-negative, remains.
Substituting our equation for XB,
we get the constraint shown here.
Of course,
XD must remain non-negative, as well.
Note that XD equals 0.
The current situation for
the algorithm is feasible, and it's easy
to see a way to improve the objective
value just by looking at the vector rD.
Our real goal, however,
is not just to climb up hill, but
to figure out which column
should enter the basis.